in the c-span area by typing the keyword
c-span
now harper's magazine editor louis
lapham in january he spoke about social
and political shifts in the united
states at the overseas press club in new
york his comments last about a half an
hour
[Applause]
well we've talked today about students
beginning in their careers we've talked
about correspondence ending their
careers we've talked about the names
aj liebling and if stone have come up
one of the things i most admire about
the profession is it has allowed some
people
to say what they mean and to stand by it
to live by it uh
lewis lapham uh editor of harper's who
subscribed yesterday's new york observer
is america's favorite grouchy magazine
editor i don't i don't think of him that
way i think of him as an iconoclast i
think him as a trenchant observer
someone who says exactly what he's what
he means and says it extremely well and
someone who provokes me uh and sometimes
elucidates sometimes provokes but i
think that's the very best tradition of
american journalism and so ladies and
gentlemen i give you lewis slapham
[Applause]
well i'm uh delighted to be here i see
many
friends in the room and i'm
sorry i didn't get the piece out of mr
frank
but
i was i thought i was going to come and
talk to a very small lunch and tell old
stories about
the days when i was a foreign
correspondent and so forth but
bill persuaded me to talk about the
new american ruling class which is a
subject to which i and how does
journalism fit into the
new order so
i'm not a marxist and i'm not a
revolutionary i'm sometimes i'm not even
a grouch but the
i know that the the word class arouses
suspicion and uneasiness in an american
audience and
i have no objection to a ruling class no
country can exist without a ruling class
that was true in uh rome in the first
century that was true in the united
states in 1787 that was true in
britain at the zenith empire and it's
true now
so the only question in my mind is what
kind of a ruling class
uh what what's the name what's its
nature what what what's the character
and what's its worth made to what
specifications
and with what's uh
passions or objectives in mind and it
seems to me that the
american
ruling class or governing class or
possessing class whatever you want to
call it
my favorite term for it is equestrian
class because that is an old roman term
the rank was for sale for four hundred
thousand
sesters in in rome and the first century
id and the and
the governing class in america is it's a
rank that is for sale
that's
also always been true in the united
states
but
something has happened to that
class over the last 50 years i think
i think it is no longer as specifically
american
class
i i think it's
lost its interest in politics
and i don't think it has much use uh for
an intelligent press
and
you now will ask me
who are we talking about
and the figures vary and numbers of
other writers have written on this
subject that bill grider has written
about it kevin phillips
christopher lash michael lind
essentially we're talking about
is that one or two percent of the
american population
that owns
90 percent of the nation's wealth and 75
percent of its capital assets
it's an oligarchy
uh
it's not a large percentage
but it's a fairly large
absolute number i mean maybe we're
talking about
two million
people perhaps
essentially these are the people who
write the laws who write the news run
the schools
direct the corporations
own the media on and on the banks
the rich and the servants of the rich
linde michael lind in his book that he
published last summer called the
american nation
uh refers to what he calls the donor
party
the donor party is the
group of no more than two hundred
thousand people in the united states
who give political campaign gifts in
excess of five thousand dollars
to become a candidate
you must be first elected
by the
donor party that is the
beginning and end of the american
democracy it's 200 000 people from
because if you don't have money you you
don't unless you're steve forbes or
perrault
you have no you you don't even appear on
television
the another way of describing the
the the oligarchy or the equestrian
class would be to just think of the
shoppers on madison avenue or rodeo
drive or the
residence of the zip code section in new
york in new york new york one zero zero
two one
which is this narrow golden rectangle in
the city of manhattan
where the annual income is something
like two billion dollars a year income
within that one
zip code section
another way to think of it would be the
way that the public broadcasting
network thinks of it which is um
i did a book show on television for a
couple of years for pbs
and
there
the pbs number which is like the
harper's number
for the
total universe of
americans
that is that makes the market for
the trade list of the new york times
books
for magazines like harper's new yorker
foreign affairs for the
documentaries that appear on pbs for
most of the leading policy journals and
so forth we're talking about no more
than two million people
if that many
that's the
whole universe
now the people that uh
essentially live within that universe um
run the schools own the banks write the
laws and so forth
um
it's the view from the box seats
and
the first thing that's changed in the
last 50 years is the sense of
responsibility
i
believe maybe i'm a romantic but i do
believe that 50 years ago
this class felt some degree of
responsibility
toward the lower borders
there was a sense that privilege
entailed obligation
there was the attitude was derived in
part from the attitude of the british
ruling class the late part of the 19th
century
from whom we
the americans picked up the
white man's burden at the direction of
rudyard kipling who wrote that poem as a
matter of fact there's a campaign speech
for teddy roosevelt
but that attitude is also confirmed by
the american victories in world war ii
and
i i happen to have been thinking great
deal about this subject lately because i
am writing a book about the
social and intellectual history of yale
university
over the second half of the american
century begin 1950 to the year 2000.
the american century as you know is a
phrase coined by henry luce yale 1919
uh former chairman of the yale daily
news and so forth and the
whole sense of american
empire american primacy american
supremacy american obligation
is very much in place
it at yale in the 1950s which is when i
was there as an undergraduate
and
several of the professors in both the
english department and the history
department were recruiters for the cia
the
sense that the of a noble mission of
bringing the
uh white to a darkened world
the careers was very much part of the
meal year
and
yale then as yale now is in the business
of making the american
equestrian class that is why one pays
26 27 000 a year to send a child to
either
yale harvard princeton or the other
universities that do this sort of thing
um
the people at
in the 50s identified themselves with an
inter with an american commonwealth
there was
an american
ideal it was an american idea there was
a sense of obligation
i don't think that the current
um
kids the the ones that i know at new
haven
or
the our current
oligarchy has the same feeling at all
i think that
the
members of the american equestrian class
today
inclined to think of themselves as
align themselves with an international
economic
order
rather than an american commonwealth
there's very little patriotism in
in this among the people that i'm
talking about
they have more in common with their
peers uh their economic peers
in england japan or germany
than they do with their
with a run of the mill americans in
omaha or sin city
and it you see it in the character of
somebody like richard nixon who was very
much at home with the
shah of iran or
marcos
or noriega people of that those are the
kind of people that he
liked could talk to understood
deep fear and hatred of the ordinary
american citizen
corporations the american corporations
today receive
much if not most of their income from
abroad
coca-cola now no longer has a domestic
division
it's a world company and
the uh
so they're not thinking in terms of the
of an american nationalist uh
economics
a lot of as you this is also obviously
true of the movie industry
which without foreign sales
cannot afford to pay the kinds of
salaries they now pay it's also true of
our
banking industries and
airlines and so on
so
it's an international
economic
uh world order and this is very clear
this is i sound like buchanan but
buchanan is right in this i don't think
this is a matter of opinion i think this
is a matter of
sheer statistics that
you can see it with
nafta you can see it
in any number of ways you i i saw it
most clearly
the year that the challenger exploded
the
six months after the
challenger exploded at t and ge were
called to testify before the senate
foreign relations committee
because the cold war was still going on
and at t and ge had decided to send up
their newest satellite on the soviet
rocket
it was the only rocket going
and the
foreign relations committee took
took this very seriously and said
you can't do this this is trading with
the enemy and so on this is our most
sophisticated
technology and so forth and so on and
the two corporations said we really
don't care what you think senator it's
not important because this is about
money
and if we don't send it up on the
russian rocket we're going to lose to
the french
we can't afford to lose to the french
and you could make the speech to you
know your friends at the council on
foreign relations but
no and goodbye
another way of looking at the
um
increasing isolation of the american
equestrian order
is in the move to the suburbs
that's everybody a lot of other people
have written about that but we now have
a
country that is becoming increasingly
feudal in its organization
we have
the united states spends
20 billion dollars a year on public law
enforcement that includes
all forms of public law enforcement
city
county
sheriff's fbi justice department so
forth we spend 40 billion dollars on
private law enforcement
again it's the the retreat
from the public
realm
privatization of everything
the private is
50 years ago
the notion of the public sector the
public sphere the public commonwealth
would have connoted a good
today in most uh
usages the word public
connotes filth squalor
incompetence
bad housing
fooled politicians
and leaking brains and so forth and the
word private is associated with the
clear
crowd streams of colorado and all good
things
flow from the private sector as opposed
to the public sector that is a
something that has happened in in 50
years
another another way you see the
uh withdrawing is the sense of
the american sense of humor
50 years ago most of the jokes or many
of the jokes were
the
have-nots
making fun of the haves
this was the
humor of menkin this was the humor of
the movies of the 30s this was the humor
of the new yorker in in the 30s and so
on
today it's reversed the humor is the
haves making fun of the have-nots
it's the humor of the david letterman
show it's the humor of pj o'rourke it's
the period it's the hero it's the it's
the humor of the
hip movies of quentin tarantino
i happen to find it very repellent but
nevertheless it is the the tone that's
in place
second thing that's happened in the last
50 years and corollary to what i'm
talking about
in terms of the character
of the american equestrian class is the
absence of interest in history or
politics
the
one would have expected
circa 1950 1955 even as late as 1960
that the
people
who enjoyed economic privilege would
also be interested in
the history of the united states uh
interested in
the intellectual content of the media of
newspapers
i went to work at
the new york herald tribune in 1960
which was the paper then owned by john a
whitney
a
leading republican
presence in in new york and on that wing
of the republican party
and he his ownership of the
tribune at the time was in the line of
pulitzer who was the democrat or greely
who was a republican or even colonel
mccormick
of the chicago papers who was
extreme what we would today call a
stream right
but whitney's interest was primarily uh
tonight a political one he hadn't had an
idea he had a political idea
and the ownership of the the papers
reflected that
they no longer do
i mean now
you would not associate i would not
associate
the corporations that own
the networks or that own the big or the
disney company or whatever the big media
syndicates are with a political idea i'd
associate them with an economic idea
with the new international
economic world order yes but with a
with an idea that
that somehow politics mattered
i wouldn't think so and and you can see
that uh
in the newspapers this morning the front
page of the times today talks about the
money likely to flow to the democrat and
republican candidates for the house in
next november's election and clearly the
lines are
the same lines as dwayne andreas the
head of
adm
who gives with the left hand to the
democrat and to the right hand with the
republican because it really doesn't
matter
there there is only
in in my view and lots of other people's
view there's only one political party in
the united states at the moment
and the point is power the point is to
be have
connection to have access to
uh
the committee or to the tax legislation
or to the
telecommunications bill or
it has very little to do with with ideas
that is again a change i think over the
last 50 years
you see this that
at on the stage at yale university you
no longer can study
political history
of american political history there are
something called cultural studies
so the historic the america the telling
of the american tale has been broken
down into telling
of the black american tale or the
feminist american tale or the ethnic
native american american tale
and so forth and so on and you can go
through the entire
you can take
as the
there is no curriculum
that went in the 60s but you know in
order to satisfy the requirement for
late 18th century history united states
you can take it in
domestic pewter
butter churns the plight of women on the
frontier and so forth all interesting
subjects but but
not a coherent
historical
view
all right if if if i'm
correct then in the
two uh points about the
american equestrian class over the last
50 years
point one being
the the feeling of no responsibility
toward
the less fortunate
and uh
to
the absence of interest in either
history
or politics
as a passionate interest
then what then becomes the uh the
function of the press
and the again the parallels to me are
very similar when i first started
working for the newspapers i my first
job was a display reporter for the san
francisco examiner in 1957 the hearst
newspaper
and i was the only
ivy league person in the
entire place
to use the word journalist was would
have been
nobody used the word journalist only
englishman and fops used the word
journalist
americans used the word reporter or
newspaper man
nobody was paid any money event to speak
of and nobody expected
to make any monies i mean there was one
did not go into
newspaper reporting to become rich
one came in for
probably in my case romantic ideas
growing out of the
depression and out of the
autobiographies of novelists on the
order of john o'hara's hemingway but the
notion was to somehow get at the truth
and tell a story
it's a romantic notion
but the
there was uh and we tended
as
as newspaper guys
to identify
with the people in the bleachers not
with the people in the box seat
and
that changed in the middle 60s by 1967
um the the ranks of the uh of the
newspaper what was the newspaper
business
begins to fill up with people from
harvard and yale and princeton
the salaries begin to go up to 300 400
000 a year for television personalities
and the identification shifts from the
uh
the crowd the bleachers
to
the swells in the box seats
and i now think that's where we are i
think we now have by and large present
company accepted a courtier press a a
i think of most of the major
news persons in the united states and i
think of
rosencrantz and guildenstern in
shakespeare's hamlet
the idea that somebody like bob woodward
is presented as an investigative
journalist is a joke
that can only be appreciated by somebody
who remembers
uh what the what investigative
journalism was that and the
i turned down as the editor of harper's
magazine
all the president's men in 19 whatever
it was 73 because there's not a single
name source
and i mean i said
okay that's gossip stuff that's great
but that's not
what i learned as a
as a journalist
and most of his
most of what now or much
of what now passes for
big time journalism is that kind of
whisper gossip
the dying bill casey of parts in my
shell-like year
the truth about iran contra et cetera et
cetera
or in the as in
where halberstam's book the best and
brightest not a single name source
conversations all invented and
reconstructed it passes in in a world
that doesn't care about history
uh as truth
the um
or as as uh as entertainment
and i i don't have to
dwell on all of that i mean but
as the
in in uh
in 1960 there was still something called
the newspaper business
literature theater movies
by 1970
all of those what were once discrete
disciplines
have been fused into something called
media
we
you know as the
politicians become less responsible
and like-minded
so do uh
so do
uh our journalists so does our
journalism i mean
to go back to the
the roman example
when
at the zenith of rome's military power
the returning general would
have a triumph through the streets of
rome
standing in the chariot
and behind him would come the train of
captured slaves and
elephants trophies and so forth
and but they would stand behind his
shoulder in a chariot they would stand
behind the shoulder there would be a man
who would say
remember
you are mortal
today our journalists we are now the
zenith of our economic power
um
the wonder of an admiring world in many
different ways
and
we ride in in triumph through the
streets of
new york or washington or london and our
media
stands behind
behind us in in the chariot and says
know that you are a god
and that's the you know essentially
that's the cover of
fortune magazine
or the you know the worship of bill
gates
and so
it's a very
dangerous attitude i think
i think we have a less and less grasp of
reality
we now have a country in which the ratio
between
what the
ceo of a corporation makes
and the lowest paid assembly worker
or clerk in the same company the ratio
is 184 to 1.
and
even as recently as 20 years ago
duration was the ratio is 15 to 1 which
is what it is in
france england and japan
and
that kind of
um
i've run out of time i'm sorry i've gone
too long but
but that
given that kind of uh world of wish
reverie dream
the public relations man is sometimes
difficult to tell from the washington
columnist
standing behind you in the chariot
whispering in your ear that you're a god
given that i i i can't think of a more
necessary
corrective
than
both the art and craft of journalism and
i'm proud to be associated with people
who
also believe that and with the
six young people who i hope will
sharpen their pencils and
go out and
do battle in the
coming days thank you
we have just just a moment or two
for a question uh i'd be interested in
it seems that the the american embrace
of a global economy and all these things
you've talked about have created critics
of the system from a buchanan on the
right but also for other voices on other
ends of the political spectrum and is
that what does that mean why is that
happening
why are there criticisms well no why
would it be that on there is a from a
liberal perspective there's criticism
and it also as well as from a populist
or right-wing perspective and it seems
to be pretty pretty broad
condemnation
well i mean there are all kinds of ways
of breaking that down i mean there are
complaints about everything i mean one
of the complaints is that the government
is not us however we define the us it is
it is a them and not a we and
and so we go around we play the game of
musical chairs as to who is the us and
to who's them and and
by
i can't possibly answer that question in
all of its but everybody's angry because
people on both the left and the right
see that the system
that something's wrong
we have a congress so futile that it
cannot negotiate a disarmament treaty
with its own citizens who own 200
million guns
or or we have a we we have a uh we have
a
uh
budget debate the government shuts down
twice in in this winter
on what essentially is i mean a balanced
budget is an imaginary number
literally i mean it happens in the out
years seven years from now which of
course never happens it's it's peter pan
it's it's
we are talking about
angels dancing on the heads of pins when
we're talking about what the
budget is going to be like seven years
from now and the government shuts down
twice
and people get
angry at that sort of thing every poll
shows
80 percent of the american people want
to protect the environment
and the and the people in washington
wave that one away that you know just go
right over that one and and begin
taking down the environmental
regulations with no
reference
to
the supposedly
nominally sovereign people
and the nominally sovereign people
are getting
very
angry properly so in my view
any other um
well thank you very much for coming
you're welcome
this
[Music]
thank you
american perspectives continues in a
minute with marilyn quail speaking on
women in the republican party first a
few program notes
tomorrow at 8 pm on book notes columnist
and commentator clarence page discusses
his recent book showing my color implied
s